Turquía ya tiene una fecha definitiva
para las próximas elecciones
presidenciales turcas que serán el 14 de
mayo unas elecciones que se prevén
claves para el futuro del país y del
presidente Turco resetta y en el poder
en Turquía desde 2003 serán clave porque
según la gran mayoría de las encuestas
publicadas en los últimos meses en
Turquía erdogan perdería estas
elecciones a mano de una posición
galvanizada por la baja popularidad
actual de erdogan debido a la grave
crisis económica a la que se afronta
Turquía desde hace algo más de un año
según datos de la propia al propio
instituto de estadísticas Turco la
inflación en Turquía se acerca el torno
del 60 y pico por ciento sin embargo
otras organizaciones independientes
marcan esta cifra en torno al 130-140
por ciento algo que se acerca mucho más
a lo que los turcos se enfrentan cada
día en las calles esas elecciones además
según la oposición serán muy complicadas
difíciles incluso injustas porque el
gobierno Turco está llevando a cabo una
campaña
desprestigio y ataque judicial y
político en contra de los partidos de la
oposición es el caso por ejemplo del
principal partido kur del tercero del
país en representación parlamentaria el
gdp que está viviendo un proceso
judicial para el cierre de este partido
alegando dice el gobierno Turco que
tiene vínculos terroristas además
también la justicia turca persigue al
alcalde de Estambul el quien es uno de
los favoritos para presentarse en contra
erdogan y que ha recibido en los meses
pasados una condena de cuatro años de
cárcel la prohibición de participar en
política para los próximos cuatro años
por haber insultado supuestamente los
miembros del comité electoral en Turquía
estas elecciones se preveberán claves
también para el futuro del país a
Turquía entre en un momento clave para
lo que será el devenir de este del país
si va a ir a una dirección o en otra
muchos turcos consideran que sierdogán
ganarse estos comicios sería
probablemente el fin de una Turquía
secular y más próxima a Europa